this is probably
one of my favorite blogs i haven't
visited in a while so let's throw this
up on the screen it's a little bit
longer it's a little bit longer but i
think that it is worth spending some
time on with this cast
share screen
window boom boom
all right so
if you don't know who jack is
he's a good dude
uh he's kind of like leave me alone sort
of guy
um
i don't care okay so you can find this
if you search at any time i'm just gonna
read it out so just you know so just
roll with me on this all right
this essay was originally published in
2014 but it's no longer available a
reader recently requested the link i
thought i'd reshare it oh looks like he
took it down anyway
these three magic words could end so
many arguments most appeals in the name
of social justice rely on an underlying
assumption of universal altruism they
assume that if that sorry they assume
that you care if something bad happens
to anyone anywhere and advise you to
take some sort of action to ease or
prevent their suffering
people react by questioning whether or
not that stranger someone is really
suffering or if they are suffering any
more than anywhere than anyone else they
examine the circumstances of the alleged
suffering and the motives of the people
bringing the alleged suffering to light
good point so far they argue sorry
sorry about that i gotta drink some more
my tea here
they argue about the details and the
proportion of the suffering and point
remember how we were talking about
victimhood
earlier
boom they argue about the details and
the proportion of the suffering and
point out their own allegedly comparable
suffering or the suffering of some
person or people who are allegedly
suffering more once you're arguing
they've already got you once you're
arguing you've agreed that you could
care or would care that you should
theoretically care given satisfactory
evidence and argumentation
but what would they say if you stopped
pretending to care at all
there would be no point in arguing about
the details of course as normal humans
we can always imagine ourselves in
another human's position
we can't empathize with others that's
what makes movies and novels work but we
really
sorry but we can't really care about the
suffering of every man and woman on the
planet the idea that we should is insane
and inhuman
so much of what people say they care
about is just emotional pornography and
can springboard them into an acrobatic
display of moral and political posturing
i see all this propaganda online telling
me what's not okay and how i'm supposed
to feel about strangers and other groups
of people
if they get me to agree that i care
about these strangers and their
unhappiness i'm supposed to accept
responsibility for that unhappiness and
do whatever i can to alleviate it this
is all manipulation a political plucking
of one bit of human suffering out of an
unimaginable expanse of human suffering
all to serve this agenda
or that one
some kid in africa probably got his head
sawed off with a butter knife while some
chick named shashina experienced a
nightmare of cat calling in new york
city
no one cared because they weren't told
to care given their perceivable social
class and sex the guys who were
expressing their admiration for shashina
have probably experienced far more
brutality than being propositioned for
sex and no one cared when it happened so
sheena is just a squeaky wheel who wants
to be lubricated with your tears
if we really cared about everyone we
would never even register feelings or
microaggressions or first world problems
because our brains would be blown out
from watching third world ultra violence
we'd be watching and liking and sharing
non-stop videos of prison rapes and
basement executions and reading stories
about sex slavery and child prostitution
we'd be outraged at the injustice of it
all 24 hours a day seven days a week
those things are happening right now and
they more or less have been happening at
varying levels for all of human history
if violence is actually decreasing
worldwide as stephen pinker suggests
then it is probably in part because due
to the high incarceration rents
high incarceration rates and widespread
fear of sanctioned violence threatened
by increasingly omnipotent surveillance
in police states in the first world and
omnipotent surveillance states are not
okay
the reason that people care about the
same thing at the same time whatever
today's outrage or viral video is is
that we all have to pick and choose we
decide if not consciously then by our
choices that one person
one person's suffering is more important
than another who we or maybe you because
i'm not talking about me here decide to
care about is completely
arbitrary whatever human tragedy passes
our eyes or ears i don't care what
happened to everyone everywhere i don't
care what happens to strangers it's an
admission that sounds barbaric and
unspeakably taboo it's taboo because
people have have never been conned into
believing that they're supposed to do
something they can never do care equally
about everyone all around the world
he goes on to say i care about what
happens to my friends my family and my
tribe i care even at this point i am
using to care very loosely about the
kind of people i generally like respect
or support people who are like me or who
are like the people i like when someone
registers an opinion or tells me i'm
supposed to care about something if i'm
even thinking about caring i look them
up i ask myself i would be interested
sorry and i asked myself if i would be
interested in what this person had to
say if they were sitting in the same
room as me you guys have heard me talk
about
ask yourself if you would exchange lives
with somebody dispensing advice to you
similar sort of concept right
sometimes i would usually i would not i
probably wouldn't even have a drink with
them or give them a single moment of my
time if they're telling me that
something bad happened to them i have to
admit that in most cases i probably
don't care
why should i care about the suffering of
the stranger instead of that one
if they're telling me that i should
change i ask why
if i'm the sorry if the only answer is
to theory uh theoretically prevent the
alleged and future suffering of some
other group of people i don't know or
care about then my answer is why bother
i'll change to some extent to gain honor
in the eyes of men i respect personally
or in the abstract but why would i
change to prevent the unhappiness of
some stranger
this idea that we are all each other
shepherds and that we are all
responsible for the happiness of all
humankind is paralyzing nonsense at best
it keeps men busy arguing about the
things over which they have almost no
control about
at worst it makes men vulnerable to all
sorts of manipulation by people who have
already decided that they are disposable
rubes now
this is exactly
what the state does right now with this
beer bug and everything that's built
around this ecosystem that the pharma
companies are all pushing
at worst it makes men vulnerable to all
sorts of manipulation how many guys have
been manipulated by all of this
nonsense that we've heard in the last
couple years
think about that
anyway i'll go on like naive write like
naive retirees given away their savings
to charity grifters or high living
evangelists men end up giving away
everything worth having to people who
are ideologically incapable of even
acknowledging their sacrifice
i'm not encouraging people to stop
caring about anyone i'm encouraging them
to stop caring about everyone
if you say you love someone you don't
really love anyone love is a choice a
discriminatory act you don't pick your
team if you aren't willing to draw the
line between who you care about and who
you don't between us and them
then you'll be like all of these other
suckers who care about whoever and
whatever they click on every morning we
live in an us and them environment
folks it's been that way throughout the
entire
human recorded history it's always us
versus them it's always going to be that
way that's never going to change no
amount of globalism liberalism or any
other ism is ever going to change the
fact that humans are actually pretty
freaking tribal
care passionately but discriminate but
discriminately and if you don't really
care then say it i don't care it's
simple but powerful it's liberating but
also dangerous and heretical the idea
that we are all in this together and are
working in good faith to solve the
world's problems is an illusion that
traps us in a criss-crossed impenetrable
web of synthetic yarn if you pull that
fuzzy pink string that completely
unwarranted assumption of universal
goodwill several sorry civil society
collapses in a hobbesian war of all
against all where no one trusts anyone
when free from our attachments to
everyone
everywhere we find ourselves adrift and
a staggering confused mass of drooling
covious humanity
we can make sense of it all from and
find our beginnings and only when a form
of discriminatory alliances and new
tribes built on trust common interests
and mutual admiration instead of being
bound to the great lie of love for all
neighbors
also the author of the book the way of
men i highly recommend you guys check
out his stuff
i don't care
that's just you know whatever it's like
oh you know you can solve it by doing
this that or the other thing or you know
between four and six rich if you taught
kids how to work on cars you know you
could you you too could save the world
that's kind of my feeling i don't care
right like
i have people in my inner circle that i
would rather dispense my time resources
and energy on not
you know some kid
four doors down that doesn't have
anybody home between four and six pm
because their parents made some bad life
choices
i don't care
mental point of origin it's a powerful
thing once you understand it right
you